well well well Jack welcome made
yourself comfortable they're going to be
here for quite some time you'll never
get away with this Drabek that is all
pick one believe us wasting your time
Drabek the military codes were destroyed
is that so I think you're bluffing
Jack and I am about to call your bluff
you see Jack I am a player in this game
but I'm also the dealer I hold all of
the cards you see Jack if I were to go
all-in you would not be able to cover
the bed
what buoy I was thinking I maybe I could
be like your torturing assistant so I
could be in the room with you and might
be that guy that stands in the
background all simulated money and that
way over there you two down with your
little ladies chat hold short Messiah
you know jack it's very apropos but do
it say that because I feel like we
should have a chat and when I say we I
mean just you and me are you a chess
player jack
sure so then you're aware that each
piece serves a different function
you see whereas you are merely a pawn
you see Jack I am The Queen I am a well
to move around the board with impunity
what is for the local [ __ ] yo man I was
thinking like maybe during yours chest
speech you couldn't suck on this
lollipop cuz and that shows him like you
so comfortable torture you just do
something stupid like stuff from
lollipop Co saying I need you to go over
there right now I need you to be still
okay oh no Paris absolutely no or
involved go over there okay shouldn't
call yourself a queen now where I'm from
let me something different than Shh
they've been waiting for this moment for
a very very long time I wanted to make
an introduction to your new best friend
I've never talked oh this will make you
talk
Jake you plus you don't even need to
stab him at first you could just like
caresses secret the blade something just
real like crazy yeah I got it I got it
are you good that's what I was planning
on doing I'm sorry where did we find you
chiquan says who is shaquan Jaquan no no
I'm asking you who he is you got kicked
into some lava so that's when I came in
okay that's wonderful I need you to go
over there
I need you to be stuck still like a
statue okay now like you [ __ ] like
keep moving in that direction now yeah
I'm good Jake the military codes are not
even the primary reason why you are here
I wanted you all to myself he's standing
back there like an actual statue isn't
he yeah that's weird
top-1 you don't have to stand like an
actual statue but literally I didn't
mean it literally ah all right I thought
that sounded stupid when you said there
originally sounds like it would be
stupid for a person to do something like
that shoes I didn't know I was like what
that doesn't make Jack today you will
experience the most exquisite pain
I'm a or mom yo got pictures of his
girlfriend
uh-huh that's it that's pretty much
torture over right there you used to
showing pictures of his girlfriend and
he'll do whatever you say there it is oh
you know what even better we got a cage
it's got a hole at the bottom so you
could put that over his head you did
another hole you put like a rat or a
scorpion up in there that's what he's
desperate the quantum all right doctors
what he's there for in the first place
all of the implements that you see on
the table that are there for a
particular lesion
what about that oh you know what look
what would you like to be involved
that's what I was thinking since the
beginning
I was thinking maybe you should just
tell them like the military codes
[Music]
you